hi guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 27th of every and you were watching
games but you first up I've got some
resolution news that word to vault into
a console war isn't that life according
to Bethesda Wolfenstein the new order
will be coming to both the ps4 and xbox
one in 1080p and 60 frames per second
both versions are the native resolution
and snot upscaled hooray for everyone
being equal let's talk about something
else today respawns have told the entire
world with no less than six exclamation
points that titanfall has gone gold if
you want familiar with the lingo that
basically means development is
completely finished and the game is
headed for mass production accompanying
the super enthusiastic tweet was an
image of the xbox one version of the
title boxed up and ready to go also a
guy on his phone who probably didn't
realize this image was going to hit
every gaming website there is how
different you reckon the final game is
going to be from the beta and do you
think we'll get any surprises let me
know your thoughts in the comments last
up we let you know how to get free stuff
because free stuff is the Vesta cerny
have revealed the game set to rock the
worlds of PlayStation Plus subscribers
next month and they're pretty good if
you've got a ps4 you can get dead nation
apocalypse addition while ps3 owners can
pick themselves up Tomb Raider Thomas
was alone and learn survived a
director's cut which are all in my
opinion excellent title you should
really get stuck into if you're one of
the aforementioned 12 people plus me who
happens to have a Vita then you'll be
able to get unit 13 and once the hunter
freedom unite and that leaves us with
the obvious question what awesome game
do you want to freak and let you know in
the comment section for commenting down
below or my Twitter wrote at just what
and that's all the news that I've got
for you today oh we really wrapped up
quickly today I guess we can just hang
around for a bit this isn't even my
watch